for Nerlens Noel as the staff went out  immediately to go to attend to him as  they're gonna put him on the stretcher  so we'll step aside here and I'll call  it a panty Wiggins let me first of all  say that folks so Nerlens Noel will head  back around the loop  ovation from this OKC crowd and that was  one of the more concerning blows that we  have seen here it's one thing when it's  a knee or an ankle but it's a whole  different ballgame when you're talking  about someone's head turnovers by the  Timberwolves attended all the very often  just the eighth of the night all of a  sudden  some emotions starting to run high here  in Oklahoma City Dennis Schroder in the  face of Jack